dozens of people were arrested in
protests over a white former police
officer acquitted in the shooting death
of a black man it happened in st. Louis
after hundreds took to the streets in a
march through the city some battling
with police into the morning hours Dean
Reynolds is in st. Louis with the latest
dean good morning good morning there
were at least 32 arrests last night as
police had to resort to using tear gas
at times to quell demonstrations that
turned violent the protest started off
peacefully as hundreds marched through
the streets of st. Louis it's a peaceful
protest there Santa's not because we're
not following their orders people are
frustrated you can't tell us how to
protest that frustration did boil over
at times into repeated clashes with
police and demonstrators took their
message directly to mayor light-up
crewson's home spraying it with paint
and breaking a window later in the
evening
the mayor appeared with the city's
police commissioner on periscope
officers did deploy pepper balls as he
left some lethal option after agitators
continued assault officers with objects
and destroyed Crocker the demonstration
started right after Jason Stockley a
former st. Louis patrolman was found not
guilty in the 2011 death of Lamar Smith
the incident caught on multiple cameras
occurred after a high-speed chase and a
collision Stockley called it
self-defense against a suspected drug
dealer Smith he said was pulling a gun
on him
prosecutors countered that Stockley seen
here retrieved a 38 caliber revolver
from the back seat of his police car and
planted the weapon in Smith's car
moments after shooting him five times
and that the gun bore only the
policeman's prints I did not murder
Anthony Lamar Smith in an interview on
Friday with the st. Louis post-dispatch
are relieved Stockley said he reacted
the best he could under the
circumstances it's very stressful and in
the end regardless of what happens
nobody wants
now Stockley who left the st. Louis
Police Department four years ago also
said everybody wants someone to blame
but I'm not the guy Dana Dean Reynolds
in st. Louis Dean thank you